oops oops right
because we're chilling and we're having
a good time and i was just about to say
something wasn't i lobbied up christian
i know that was just about to take out
the grenade no you know what i'm not
going to pull out the grenade because
i'll tell you right now we've been we've
been doing this a lot yeah i demerit you
every week right hey man dude no no i'm
going to try a different time don't what
are you going to do now
look out
oh there you go dude the oops
doesn't drop in a week i'm giving you
something
no it's very nice dude
and i want to reward you for being a
good friend and maybe you'll learn that
way i like it it's not a shitty gift it
better not be a shame open it
and you don't take too long with them
you have a lot of outfits no
but i could ruin them
you take too long timing is everything
okay so open it quicker you couldn't
just untie the knife it's okay don't be
nervous
dude my son opens stuff better than you
do he's not too young hey but it's good
paper look how heavy the paper is very
good dude you did not since you
interrupted me i thought i'd get you a
gift oh
[Music]
hang it up above your bed
i'm not doing that and kiss it before
you go to sleep no dangling off your
teeth
yeah dude whoops i don't have anything
or or we'll put it back there no
you know what you should do whatever
you're wearing put it here i won't do
that dude and b oops
flavor flame it because you're oops man
doctor interrupted yeah that's who you
are you want me to wear it like this oh
yeah okay so everyone knows again you
walk up they gotta be quiet
i heard you first time you piece of [ __ ]
all right
putting it right here it's hilarious
who the [ __ ] made this it's a nice it's
it's actually i've got a crafty fiance
oh dude she's doing arts and crafts when
we were doing the show exactly that's
all she goes are you into painting i
went what
brought her she was she's like i gotta
go on stage she was painting behind the
merch table just painting [ __ ] in san
diego she was doing the same thing she's
like you down to pain i'm like
no no
she told me she told me i was actually
like
she told me that she was like i asked
brenda to paint it was so funny and i
was like oh yeah what do you say she was
like i don't know i gotta i don't know
maybe later
i know he
maybe let me uh i'm going on in five so
i'll come back and yeah if you have this
stuff